the charred wreckage of the bus makes
clear how intense the fire must have
been
the vehicle crashed and burned on a
bulgarian highway in the middle of the
night it was taking mostly north
macedonian tourists back home after a
weekend trip to istanbul but it's not
yet known why so few people made it off
alive or what caused this disaster in
the first place this damage suggests the
bus hit a barrier before carrying on to
crash into the central reservation
bulgaria's interior minister said he was
deeply shocked by what he'd seen
not everyone can stand such a picture
the picture is terrifying
the details of this tragedy will be
investigated
north macedonia's foreign minister
visited survivors in hospital in
bulgaria's capital sophia
i'm here in the hospital to get more
information what we know is that a
horrible tragedy has happened here in
bulgaria with the bus that carried north
macedonia nationals who were traveling
from istanbul to scorpio there were over
53 passengers on the bus dozens of them
are children over 40 were killed some of
the wounded were transferred here but
let me first see the situation and i'll
be back later with more
police in north macedonia have begun an
investigation into bezatrans the bus and
travel company
this man came to its shuttered office in
north macedonia's capital skopje looking
for news of his nephew
i saw information about the crash at 6am
this morning i saw it on the internet
and as my nephew was in turkey i started
searching on the internet
i called bezetrans for the number for
three four hours we do not have any
information for them nor are they
answering their phone
and the investigation continues by
daylight on the struma highway into the
worst bus crash in bulgarian history
rory challenge now to zero